We've got one more segue
option to explore.
There's a third way to present a view
controller using only a storyboard
segue, no code.
But don't worry.
I haven't forgotten that we still
need to figure out how these
two view controllers should communicate.
We'll get those dice values set,
I promise.
We're going to take this segue that
we added earlier and delete it.
And we'll replace it with a segue that
goes directly from the roll the dice
button to the dice view controller.
We also need to remove the action
from this roll the dice button.
The action that's connected
to touch up inside, that is.
And finally, let's close our
outline view for a second.
Open up the utilities pane,
click on that segue, and
go into the attributes inspector.
That's where we'll set the storyboard
identifier for this segue.
And we're going to call it rollDice.
And now we'll run it.
Our view is appearing as expected,
but still no dice.
I think it's time to get these two view
controllers talking to each other.